hey y'all we know it's been way too long
since we've released merch but today is
your lucky day we're so excited to
announce our collaboration with artist
and designer jasmina zornik available
now you can rock this
or
this or this
all right you'll get the point i think
everything is so dope and you need to go
check it out right now on the website
and order yours go to
shop.jubileemedia.com to check out our
newest drop
now we hope you enjoyed the episode
should we start birthdays too yeah yeah
yeah we're born on july 21st oh wait
wait wait
we brought together seven pairs of twins
we are twins we're twins we are twins
we're twins we are twins we are twins
we're twins
one pair of twins is a liar if the group
discovers who the liar is they'll split
a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize
who is the odd one out
who's identical who's fraternal
identical everyone looked pretty
different it wasn't like oh someone's
going to be twins and it's guaranteed i
will say our zodiac sign at the same
time
one's a gemini okay interesting
i instantly thought it was going to be
dish and amber amber
they looked at least similar we could be
like cousins yeah we don't even look
like yeah so we don't really go off of
looks like everyone's gonna go off looks
though you know when my
mom called my dad and told him that he
was having twins he was so in shock that
he said it isn't mine
started crying it was they went in to
find out the gender and they were like
okay so it's gonna be a girl and then
baby b is also going to be a girl
is there like twins in your family he's
like no we're the first
cousins
[Music]
honestly it was so hard to tell because
everyone was being so polite everyone
like had a chance to think about it and
time it it felt like we just barely got
the pleasantries out and was like okay
[Music]
seeing maybe what pair didn't have the
most chemistry and and that pair i guess
they didn't get the chance to speak
they were a little less assertive there
were certain people who stood out as
twins right away
[Music]
oh
i mean it was expected yeah but i was
like just feel us like come on just like
feel it like because i think if we got
in another round we've been able to
convince them that we were twins oh yeah
should we start birthdays too yeah yeah
yeah our birthday is july 23rd so it's
on wednesday but we'll see our current
right now yeah we're 17. yeah well we're
august first and we're eight to 18.
we're born on july 21st oh wait wait you
guys oh july 24th
[Music]
the second that davina and julia messed
up their birthdays i was like
i was shocked it's kind of weird you're
twins but you don't know each other's
birthday concisely we are april april
21st we were supposed to be born on
april 20th but that was our mom's
birthday so she literally said i'm not
sharing my birthday with two two people
on january 12 and we're thirty and we're
twenty one yeah february 25th and we're
21.
okay what was going to school like did
you guys go to the same school oh yeah
were you like separate so we went to the
same elementary school in preschool up
until about third grade obviously the
theater person i'm the sports person
yeah just like we're doing right now we
went to the same high school and we were
going different colleges yeah we were
each other's only friends we were super
shy we didn't talk to people so we were
like the creepy like shining twins yeah
like our mom was like
i was suspicious of lauren and kit um
just simply because they had a really
great stage presence they were talking
the most and it could have been like
very well rehearsed a little bit we're
actually we were born in cairo egypt so
we went in elementary school and middle
school we went there and then we went to
high school and here total shock and
then like just having like just having
someone who went like through identical
circumstances and like i don't think
like any friend or any sibling on earth
can have like this uh this i wonder
though the experience is different for
boy girl twins
versus fraternal of the same sex which
do you guys tell each other everything
yeah like most things yeah
yeah we do and it's funny because like
there'll be some like girl things that
like usually a guy wouldn't know about
but of course like
vice versa
[Music]
i noticed they do have different eyes
could these be like best friends who
found each other and were like we look
exactly alike we're pretty much twins
they're definitely related
but they could also be
not twins
[Music]
[Applause]
please raise your hand if you still have
doubt
and want to continue playing the game in
three two
one
it's too early
i have a question for everyone i feel
like someone who is not a twin would
feel like the relationship between twins
would be amazing so i want to ask
everyone like what is your least
favorite part about being for us i feel
like the most annoying thing about being
twin is like the constant comparison it
is like worse especially since we're
identical oh yeah and like growing up
like kind of like starting to look more
different and like she's the pretty one
so i get insecure like
it just it just like happens and like
constantly like everybody looking at you
being like oh like you guys you guys
look different like this is what's
different about you it just gets really
annoying about our personalities too we
used to look very alike it sucks because
i understand what you're saying because
now we feel like we look different
enough but going up like legitimately i
had a boy come up to me in seventh grade
and be like i know the difference
between you and your sister and i was
like what he's like you're the fatter
twin and i just like they pick the worst
parts of you and point it out like you
don't do that to normal people but
you're doing it because you feel like
you have a case study could you imagine
identical yeah yeah i think so you're
identical
people never believe us when we say
we're identically it felt like all of
the other sets of twins who were
fraternal have a completely different
dynamic than we did it's not everything
that it's like made up to be like the
comparison gets so tiring i think yeah
growing up we would fight a lot like you
said um there are a lot of differences
between us especially when we were
younger but
as we've grown up we've kind of we've
matured and we're not fighting over
silly things but um
yeah how many minutes are you guys apart
again
yeah we should all go in the center and
say like one nice thing about each other
[Laughter]
angie you are the most talented athlete
i know and i'm so excited for you to run
cross country and track this fall in
college division one athlete right here
you guys oh that's so cute you inspire
me every day because of your big heart
and your outgoing spirit because you
know you do theater and that's hard for
a guy sometimes so
i love you
that was interesting because it was it
was so prepared hey they just stuck out
in my head i was like for a while i was
not doubting them
well you are like a built-in best friend
no matter like even if i were to lose
all my friends like i could lie with you
i could still always have you and
i love you too and i know things have
been tough at home and so it's really
nice to have you there for me i can't
feel it
okay
i love you you light up every room you
walk into you are just the shining light
and and you just make everyone feel
comfortable
you're almost my test guinea pig i get
to find out what i like because you're
brave enough to do it first
love you buddy
when we moved here i was just i was
feeling extremely extremely homesick and
then
it's just
you were there and you understood
everything every time i'm mad you just
understand why i'm mad even sometimes
when our parents don't understand it and
like you're my
i don't want to say just best friend
because you're more than my best friend
i don't know
can i give you another hug
elvia you're the hardest working person
that i know you
inspire and you motivate me every single
day like i really admire your humility
your confidence your drive to succeed
and i know that no matter what happens
like you're gonna be you're gonna be
amazing and you're you're my everything
like thank you
yeah i love you oh my goodness no i
don't know what to do
i know that they called each other buddy
i wouldn't call my brother buddy
i would call someone who's like more of
a friend that i'm not too close to buddy
they didn't talk much i was like they're
shy but like their conversation probably
was not as deep as the others
[Music]
please raise your hand if you still have
doubt that you caught the moles and want
to continue playing the game in three
two one
i thought we got the mole out already
yeah i thought we got the mole out in
the first two rounds that's what's
tricky like better safe than sorry to
not keep playing okay well i think that
if we play another round if you're not
the mole then you have nothing to worry
about that's right
and it's better to be safe than sorry so
i feel like potentially they could we
everything we just did very much in my
mind solidified the fact that it's a
very good chance we already caught them
all i say and i think we're just we can
save yeah something like really really
deep only twins wouldn't know that
no hard feelings yeah but i feel like
we're definitely twins i feel like you
guys can just be brothers or something
really quickly what year did you
graduate 2018. when's your birthday
january 12 2000.
okay okay
he want to be when he grew up i know
he's gonna say i've been really hard i
don't think he always wanted to go
dennis that was like a amazing thing he
wants to be a but we have the same major
which is biology weird okay but we're
different schools i'm afraid of like
going into like something new yeah so
he's like he always helps me like try
new things like the most annoying twin
questions yeah that you get about being
twins
where's your twin why is your twin not
going with you to the gym
anything that's like
i don't want to say stupid but like
like like something that just means they
oblivious about what twins
i would say i'm most suspicious of them
that i'm a little bit i am a little bit
suspicious of you i just felt like maybe
you are
cousins and your speech was just a
little bit more like a
very very close friend potentially a
civilian yeah the only thing is because
we all have like the same gender
dynamics
it's crazy because you know boy and girl
but we also have like different
interests something that i've noticed in
the differences between you guys versus
us is we all are like we finished our
off sentences
michael and peter kept bringing up like
the cliche things of being a twin rather
than the things that like you have to
know by being a twin everybody else
looked identical we were obviously
fraternal twins you know i didn't want
them to vote us out
[Music]
good luck you guys oh you expected it we
yeah we know we're going to be out but
like we had a little bit of help but
like we were like okay yeah everyone is
like suspecting us how do you prove that
you're 20. it's very difficult to do
that please raise your hand if you want
to continue playing the game in three
two one
[Music]
[Laughter]
the light turns green that means you
have voted out the moles and you win
if the light turns red that means the
moles are still in the box and you lose
hope you guys made the right decisions
[Applause]
will the fake twins please step forward
and reveal yourselves
in three
two
one
[Applause]
i have a twin
adopted john's story and like because i
like already have that like experience
as a twin like we should be able to have
at least a good chance
i think it's different for like
fraternal versus identical though they
have like a different experience of like
always getting like compared to each
other though we have very different
lifestyles we always have like that
special place to come back to we're the
same person split in half only
understand it if you are a twin people
always are like oh do you guys have like
twin telepathy and like
yeah of course obviously yeah
[Music]
[Applause]